veíamos y hablábamos que 142 Marines
fueron los que jalaron el carruaje
fúnebre de la reina A qué se debe esto y
que ya no se utilicen caballos como se
hacía antes Bueno resulta que toda esta
procesión que estamos viendo Es
tremendamente planeada porque resulta
que cuando se murió la reina Victoria no
lo fue el problema fue que la reina
Victoria designó que quería que ocho
caballos de color blanco y unos crema
tiraran de su carruaje de su cortejo
fúnebre Cuál fue el problema los
caballos se despistaron y casi cae el
féretro de la reina a raíz de esto el
abuelo del de Felipe del Duque de
edimburgo Luis debatenberg ordenó que
los soldados tomaran ese carruaje en ese
momento eran 138 Marines y desde
entonces se mantiene esa tradición y de
hecho este funeral fue
calculada mente planeado teníamos la
operación London Bridge o puente de
Londres a qué se debe esto y qué común
es tener todo uno operativo montado
antes de que muera El Monarca británico
bueno Esto es como les digo desde la
reina Victoria porque cuando ella murió
fue súper sorpresivo Entonces desde ese
momento ni siquiera sabían qué hacer
Cómo actuar no sabían nada Incluso a la
persona que estaba encargada de la Touch
se le quedó el ataúd tuvieron que hacer
un ataúd en Londres que no era de Roble
era de otro material la reina Victoria
no quería ser embalsamada Entonces al no
querer ser embalsamada fue un lío
terrible tuvieron que meterle carbón al
féretro Además ella dejó una serie de
instrucciones un poco confusas nadie
sabía que hacer les tocó echar a patadas
al alcalde de todo entonces fue una
confusión terrible que dijeron Esto no
puede volver a pasar si se muere un
monarca por lo que ella había durado 64
años en el trono Entonces desde entonces
se tiene el pasito a pasito de que se
debe hacer para evitar toda esa clase de
convulsiones